[Music]
cw's riverdale to your buddy mark
fellows and Luke Perry our Hollywood
dads but before that these heartthrobs
were just trying to find their way
Cameron like many of their cast mates as
easy on lines win Aguilera found out
what would you say to these two young
uns I would tell this game is please
don't wear that what haircut is that
beaver
it's the bowl cut imagination is getting
the better of you mark and Marisol
Veronica's parents on the show are a lot
more buttoned up than they were back in
the day what would you say to your
younger self get a stylist
Luke playing Archie's dad was a fashion
plate even before nine oh two one oh
great shoestrings yeah I love them shoe
strings man that's kind of a mullet in
it that was rockin the mullet pretty
hard there for a while and as for this
young lady
any chance of Kelly joining mark on
Riverdale I'm hope there's some
interesting things that could happen I
stopped asking I asked a little bit last
year it was the point
you